8 مليارات نسمه هذا هو العدد الذي يصل
اليه سكان العالم في الخامسه عشر من
نوفمبر تشرين الاول
2022 رغم بعض اي معدل النمو ليست لحظه
يحتفل بها الجميع بالضروره حيث يشعر البعض
بالقلق من عالم مزدحم بعدد كبير جدا من
السكان وموارده غير كافيه للعيش على
اساسها لكن الرقم يشكل بكل تاكيد علامه
فارقه في التنميه البشريه والنمو غير
المسبوق يرجع الى زياده التدريجيه في عمر
الانسان بسبب التحسينات في الصحه العامه
والتغذيه والنظافه الشخصيه والطب كما انه
ناتج عن مستويات الخصوبه العاليه
والمستمره في بعض البلدان يظهر تقرير
الامم المتحده ان الهندسه تتجاوز الصين
اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث عدد السكان
عام 2023 كما تشير التوقعات الى ان عدد
سكان العالم يمكن ان ينمو الى نحو 8
مليارات ونصف مليار في عام 2030
وتسعه مليارات و 700 مليون نسمه في عام
2050 قبل ان يصل الى ذروته عند 10 مليارات
و400 مليون نسمه خلال عام 2080 ومن
المتوقع ان يظل عدد السكان عند هذا
المستوى حتى عام 2100 ماذا ذلك تشير
الدراسه السنويه التي صدرت بالتزامن مع
اليوم العالمي للسكان الى ان عدد سكان
العالم ينمو بابطا معدل له منذ عام
1950 بعد ان انخفض الى اقل من واحد في
المئه في عام 2020
سيتركز اكثر من نصف الزياده المتوقعه في
عدد سكان العالم حتى عام 2050 في ثمانيه
بلدان هي الكونغو ومصر واثيوبيا والهند
ونيجيريا وباكستان والفلبين وتنزانيا على
العالم ان يكون مستعدا ايضا لرؤيه المزيد
من الشعر الابيض بحلول عام 2050 اف سيصبح
عدد الاشخاص الذين تبلغ اعمارهم 65 عاما
وما فوق في جميع انحاء العالم اكثر من ضعف
عدد الاطفال دون سن الخامسه
يوصي تقرير الامم المتحده الدول
بالاستثمار في زياده تطوير مواردها
البشريه من خلال ضمان الوصول الى الرعايه
الصحيه والتعليم الجيد لجميع الفئات
العمريه وتعزيز فرص العماله المنتجه
والعمل اللائق اذ ان تحقيق اهداف التنميه
المستدامه خصوصا تلك المتعلقه بالصحه
والتعليم
والمساواه بين الجنسين سيسهم في خفض
مستويات الخصوبه وابطاء النمو السكاني
العالمي